foreign
[Music]
some results that uses cryptography to
prove uh competitive theoretic
statements so I believe it will be
interesting to both competitors and
cryptographers so I put this slide in
the very beginning of my talk uh hoping
that both competitors and cryptographers
will have some kind of takeaway message
uh so if you are a competitive service
then maybe you are interested in the
empty harness of meta complexity this is
one of the central things in this
program
so what we prove is uh the MP harness of
the so-called mlcsp problem minimum
article circular size problem I'll have
a definition a few slides later
uh actually this is not what we prove
this is what rafaelango proved three
years ago he introduced this problem as
some uh like testing ground for studying
mtsp and he showed this problems NP
complete however he didn't show good
empty harness of approximation and this
is what we do in our work we show mlcsp
is NP hard to approximate uh with a new
optimal in approximation Gap
uh if you are a complexities then our
proof might have another point that you
might get interested in that is we okay
we don't need PCP at all uh if you are
familiar with like what raffle and
Switzer did previously the other work
starts with some in your personality
result in the PCP literature and then
translate it into and behind us on meta
complexity while like preserving the
hardness of approximation in contrast we
started with vanilla exact color and we
got some uh empty harness of
approximating metal complexity with very
large approximation Gap
okay now for the cryptographers
um
first uh it's a long known that there's
a very intimate connection between
cryptography and The Meta complexity I
hope that uh this results will be uh
will add some something new in this
connection so
uh in this talk you might see how we use
crypto constructions to prove something
interesting in complexity Theory and
it's not the kind of a basic fundamental
crypto construction as you may think
like one way functions or PK it's
something quite Advanced with this
encryption and uh our results are
unconditional
uh so hopefully you are now kind of
curious how we use Windows inclusion to
prove something unconditional I'll leave
this at like later in the talk hopefully
this uh getting somewhat excited I don't
know uh
another takeaway message I want I hope I
can convince the cryptographers is that
uh you have the right technique and the
right perspective to make progress in
metal complexity I hope you I hope I can
convince you at the end of this talk uh
so uh let me start uh so the last slide
is the zero slide of this talk and this
is the first slide uh
um let me uh start by gentle
introduction of the memory Circle sets
problem
which was serve the motivation of this
talk and the problem just asked given
the truth table of a Boolean function
was the second complexity of this
suitable
uh let's keep the notational convention
that the function is a little unwarried
functional and the truth table lens will
be capital in which is two to the little
n
um
so we want to study the meta complexity
of circuit complexity the complexity of
mtsp what is known it's easy to see that
mtsp is a problem in mp because you can
simply guess the circuit which has set
polynomial in capital n and you can
verify the circuit computes 0 to symbol
in polynomial in capital in time
and this problem is intractable if one
of my functions exist this is like
implicitly improved in the natural paper
and explicitly proved in complex type of
the paper that introduce them since p uh
this is like one of the first instances
that shows uh the intimate connection
between console and meta capacity and
there are certainly more connections
uh the central open program it was an
empty speed NP complete and the next
slide will have some motivational uh
like in my opinion or why we care about
MP components of mtsp uh
so the first reason is of course
curiosity mtsp is a very natural problem
a series studied practitioner studied
and we still don't have a like natural
complexity class that characterizes the
difficulty of this problem uh despite
like 50 years of study uh
so uh learning leveling published the
paper on mp complainers uh in 1973 like
50 years before but he could have
published it uh one or two years earlier
he was trying to prove factoring graph
isomorphism and the mcsp are empty
complete and he tried one year or two
and he couldn't do that
so uh
hahaha yeah
it's close
this is a story I don't know
oh
it's on his webpage so it's totally true
after 15 years we still don't have a
good idea on whether it should be MP
complete
some barrier results of the form if
entropy is empty heart under blah blah
blah kind of production then blah blah
blah happens
how do you like how do you interpret
this result first we actually believe
exp is not equal to zpv we just don't
believe like we will see a proof in one
year so so this result actually doesn't
tell you if mtsp should be MP hard it
might be the case that if you assume
this little brown then you can get empty
hundreds of mcsp or it might be the case
that it's not and be complete at all
uh the result just tell you this open
problem it's someone it's some open
phone that's hard to solve but it
doesn't tell you whether it should be
empty company or not so I think one of
the uh like one motivation of studying
and becoming business of enthalpy is
simply our curiosity we don't know this
is a natural problem we have no clue
uh and some other motivations include uh
like this is more uh more pragmatic ones
include excluding her sticker so in a
very nice table uh
showed that if cap M50 is MP hard
and the worst case an average case
comparative MPI products so if you
followed his talk then you are not this
corresponds to excluding heuristica
[Music]
um
and also a very nice sequence of work by
Leon pass showing uh like uh some
version of meta complexity the average
case compressive sound version of metal
complexity corresponds to one-way
functions so if you show meta complex
problems are empty complete uh maybe you
also make progress on this on a building
a cryptography from female assumptions
and uh that's uh I just listed a few
motivations for studying and becomes of
mjsp
and here is the main protagonist of this
talk so minimal Oracle circuit that
problem
uh Russell uh introduced this problem uh
and uh called it approaching entity from
above
uh the definition of This Promise is as
follows even a function f and an Oracle
o both represented as two Stables
you want to compute the O Oracle circuit
complexity of f so is there a circuit of
certain sides that uses and or not and
Oracle gets the computer
uh Rahul suggested that this is a
testing ground for mtsp uh one like one
evidence is that the barrier result I
mentioned before also works for ML sales
speed so if you can show mlcsp it's
gonna be hard using these music
reductions then you still get exp not
equal to dpb
uh however uh it might be a surprise at
that time that Rahul also showed This
Woman's Indian empty heart on the
randomized reductions
so uh like one take away might be uh the
barrier result just says the domestic
reductions are weak in some sense and
maybe you you should consider randomized
reductions
sorry can you explain the problem again
what is the O Oracle what does that mean
oh so you're uh on the input I mean you
don't have to call that work with the
computer in the input you are given
future Stables the first line is the
function we want to compute the second
one is the truth of Oracle then you want
to find the minimal side of Oracle
circuits that computes your thriftable
hopefully it's clear I see no no that is
clear now thank you
is this some kind of related to the
conditional probability oh yes uh you
can think of it as a circle version of
conditional outcomes uh we we also have
empty companies about four conditional
control competitors but I didn't mention
it in this talk
okay so here is something that wasn't
addressed so very well interest work
that did hundreds of applications
[Applause]
foreign
approximation problem so the es
instances have complexity as no
instances have complexity something like
uh two two one of Epsilon and times as
so this is if you look at it this is
actually a very large gap because uh the
maximum circuit complexity is around 2
and
uh and uh
what is gap
uh the es instance has completed as no
instance has 0.1 little n times s so the
truth table length is uh two children
but the Gap is only like linear in
moreover you cannot help to improve it
using rahul's technique because it comes
from set color and for cell cover a
login approximation is optimal
for every app store
uh I don't know I think uh what should
road towards like for every episode
foreign
uh actually it's stronger uh in our yes
instances uh RS instances are exactly
computed by size as there are no
instances are average case hard against
sets two to one last Epsilon n times s
uh so the parents work are only
considered no instances that are worst
case hard for scientists but in our
reduction we can show average case
hardness in the no instances
uh so this slide represents our results
any questions so far
under which reductions oh random mapping
reductions randomized mapping reduction
cup production okay did you say you
needed to assume some cryptography uh uh
we use the photographic about this
result is unconditional okay
and uh any other questions
if there are no then the rest are
techniques
uh maybe a photographer as well be
interested in the rest because they are
quite cryptographic first let me give
you some intuition on why cryptography
helps
for me one intuition it's like
cryptography gives you structured
hardness
um so recall that MP hundreds of mcsp uh
implies yes P naught equal to jbp so you
need to assume some harness or some
lower bounds to prove empty handles of
mcsp but uh they doesn't seem enough so
if you just assume circular bonds it's
still unclear how to prove and behind us
of mcsp what about assuming crypto
crypto hardness the like a huge arsenal
of crypto hardness like
America uh concrete assumptions like
learning with error and The Primitives
like IO and snug and something and maybe
you can play with all these assumptions
combine them and somehow get empty
handles of ancest uh
I I don't know but uh this sounds like a
possibility so
another intuition which is uh actually
it's quite formal so it's too formal to
be an intuition another line is that uh
cryptography gives you arguments and the
arguments are empty handles of meta
complexity
uh you can see it on the next slide
um so now I claim an argument system
it's essentially empty handles of meta
capacity for some meta complexity
problems uh why is it the case
first what is an argument system for a
language is there is some language in NP
you have an argument system for l so if
x is in L then there's a size as plural
with a witness of X that can convince
over there like in some sense convince
the welfare
if x is nothing else then any plural of
some sides uh cannot convince the
welfare except with negligible
probability and if you stare at the
definition for five seconds five four
three two one uh you can see this is a
reduction
[Laughter]
foreign
hopefully this is clear
and uh you can see this perspective
gives you not only empty handles of
metal complexity but also hardness of
approximation with a virtually large you
know possibility Gap so you can adjust
the security parameter to make this Gap
not just the 10th power but as large as
possible
um
and the second remark is that the no
instances are average case hard because
every side has set a certain floor only
have like negligible probability of
convincing the welfare
so uh argument systems are really like
very suitable for proving NP hundreds of
metal capacity with essentially the
largest possible approximation Gap
now if you want to show mlcsp it's
something complete uh what's the
argument system you need
I guess someone will uh will not agree
this is an argument system but in the
from the perspective of and behind the
metal campuses this this should be oh so
people who I think were confused because
you don't have any assumptions but
you're using cryptography but is it
because you can pick the Oracle o random
Oracle and do the crypto uh yes but it's
not a random Oracle it's some uh like uh
let me see further it so it's generic
multilinear map
so in this Oracle you have Uncle you
know and that's why our results are
unconditional anyway uh
let me introduce uh witness the
encryption in case that you I guess many
of you are familiar with it but maybe
some of you are not
uh
any comment
oh it's not no problem
um so what witness encryption allows you
to do it's you have a public set
instance just think of it as three main
process and you can encrypt something
using this public side instance so
anyone with a proof of remote hypothesis
can decrypt this message
more formally uh you have uh so evidence
encryption scheme gives you the
following two algorithms first is
encryption it takes uh the remain
hypothesis uh some secret message and
some Randomness as input and output the
ciphertext decryption takes Raymond
hypothesis a proof of real hypothesis
and the several text and recovers this
message
the correctness oh first uh in this talk
let's assume that decryption is
deterministic encryption has to be
randomized but for Simplicity level
system decryption is not
uh the com uh correctness says if like
my proof of Rhema hypothesis it's indeed
true the the decryption will give you
the correct message
security says
if ruin my hypothesis it's false then uh
the encryption of two different messages
are computationally indistinguishable
um so not that this definition doesn't
tell you anything about the case that
women hypothesis it's true but we don't
know how to prove it I think this is a
down for purpose so the gjsw the people
who defined Windows encryption business
for photos but anyway we have
correctness for uh fair being
satisfiable and we're having a witness
and the security for onset style
performance
uh
uh here is how our result becomes
unconditional we consider witness
encryptions in Oracle Works in
particular everybody has access to some
specifically designed or alcohol or
encryption decryption are they all have
access to all correctness says sales is
the same security says uh effects on
that power button you need to make like
exponentially manicure to all in order
to decipher the server text
uh there are some some important
technical details that I want to tell
you first the Oracle standing is only
like oh Lambda instead of oh length of
5. if Oracle finding is all length of 5
I believe uh Oracle witness encryption
is easy to construct
but if Oracle fan is only all Lambda
then it's it's quite non-trivial to
construct such Oracle in this encryption
second uh uh so you can see that our
conference or Lambda and Oracle lens is
2 2 or Lambda which will be polynomial
in the set instance length and that
makes our reduction for normal time
because we need to write the whole
Oracle into our truth table
also we all need some exponential
security but let's not worry about this
um
so uh q and this notion Maybe
you may wonder if this thing
unconditionally exists and second if
this exists then it can be used to prove
empty handles of mlcsp and this is
exactly what we do in this work
um any questions so far
okay
first let me tell you how to get empty
handles of mslp using Oracle witness
encryption
um
yes although it seems that if it does
then also it's also okay I don't know
our reduction it doesn't
oh I'll tell you what our reduction is
in this slide
oh no no no no you you are sitting in
this slide okay it's not reduction to
mssp2 some Oracle
okay so given a step instead we want to
produce and I'm also at P instant F and
O 2005 specifical event only app has
small oracles that are complexity
so uh can you see clearly this is f our
suitable F will be a random truth table
and our Oracle always consists of two
parts
uh the first part is some Oracle on the
rich the witness encryption secure when
this encryption exists so
we not only have an oracle or under
which the security encryption we can
actually sample the suitable of this
Oracle in polynomial time and you just
sample this Oracle and it's om
O2 is some Oracle that hides the sample
text of each fi so we have capital N
entrance in the truth table for each
entry we put an encryption of this entry
into O2
does this make sense
uh I guess uh intuitively it should be
clear that this things like a correct
reduction
first if five is satisfiable then the
correctness of Our Winning institution
will imply that F has a small Oracle
circuit because the Oracle circuit is
like this
only input I really had called a witness
of 5 and the current Oracle O2 to obtain
the encryption of f i then use the
decryption algorithm with awareness to
obtain F of I
and uh for the no case in fact
unsatisfiable then uh the any small or
alcohol circuit that computes F can be
used to violate the security of witness
inclusion
in fact any small circuit that has some
good correlation with f can well as the
security of Windows encryption so uh in
the notice we also get average case hard
to tables
uh this needs a natural proof I guess I
used some hybrid arguments and the
complexity leveraging but I hope the
intuition should be clear
so if there's no problem
Oh yes that's true
oh I believe if you can make all two
independent of of fat then it will be
very interesting
Okay so
now we are left with the problem of how
to construct a Oracle witness encryption
if you are I at the point uh what should
you do you just look at all of the
candidates witness encryption proposing
literature one by one and for each one
you try to construct Oracle to make them
secure uh this looks like a big project
but unfortunately the first paper that
introduces women's encryption is good
so so we looked at the first paper and
uh and the uh came up with some
um like where is the Oracle that makes
this occur no the security proof it's
not easy but
um
so we looked at what ggsw did uh it uses
multi-linear map so we constructed some
Oracle with uh like with secure model in
a map
and then we proved this is secure EG
wrote 10 pages of very technical proofs
to show this is secure so
why is it not approved in the paper that
why is the proof in the paper not good
enough oh did they prove any security
oh yeah I remember
um
[Applause]
[Music]
wow oh that's a very interesting
it's a different picture
you needed to look at four more papers
or something
anyway and I will not tell you how to
prove the security today because I think
it's practically cost I just want to
show you the construction uh so let's
review
there by the way some issue that your
security parameter is like a log of the
statement size which usually if like
like in crypto the adverse they usually
can run in like poly statement size so
like make all the queries to their
Oracle oh the security parameter is like
large constant times login and uh
there's some small content Epsilon said
that two to ethanam that says otherwise
I cannot break your windows information
but also the works on the obfuscation
using small Hardware tokens is beautiful
around we have some fairly simple yeah
so the even before the
I don't remember the timeline but if you
have like small pieces of stateless
Hardware which you can think
oh that's very interesting yeah let's
talk about it offline
so uh here is some review of the gjsw
construction
uh our starting point is the exact color
problem which is among the first MP
complete problems discovered by carbs
uh in this problem we have a universe of
Set n and some subsets X1 up to XM we
want to see uh if there are like some
subjects that exactly covers the
universe which means uh the subset
should be disjoint pelvis disjoint and
the destroyed Union should it should
equal to the universe
think of it as you have some jigsaw
puzzle pieces and you want to select
some pieces that completes the jigsaw
puzzle
uh so here it's an insecure version of
ggsw Let's assign a random number RI to
each element I in the universe and for
instead as it's our value will be the
sum of all our values of its elements
so
we announced R of the universe and each
of x i to the public
and the decryption reduces to finding
like uh the subset spending some
substance whose r value adds up to the
to out of the universe so this is the
intuition and and because you need to
like encrypt one bit you need some small
adjustment of this idea to implement it
so
um besides hour after iron we also
sample RN plus one and the RN plus two
as random numbers and let's say the
message bit we want to encrypt is either
M plus one or M plus two this is
equivalent to encrypting zero or one
so we'll announce our M plus 1 RM plus
two
our universe you need a message and each
of x i
the question is just using the witness
for exact color to find out the universe
and then given up the universe you can
figure out the message by comparing it
with these two numbers
hopefully this is clear
and uh it the security I I have no idea
it may be just a simply in Secure but
you can use some Oracle to uh in some
sense office case the plus operation and
to make it secure
so this is the multilinear map model
okay so here is a crash course on
multinational map given by Henley who is
who doesn't know anything about
multilingual map
uh we start with group G1 up to GN plus
one
for each group GI it will be used to
obfuscate stats uh whose size is exactly
I and each job is exactly group of other
people so this just means uh like HGI in
each GI we have additional model appear
and each group GI is paired with some
random projection Sigma I think of Sigma
I as giving labels to the group elements
so the labels will be random
given a label you don't know what the
group element is
uh
and for I said s that's suppose uh like
like K is the size of the set then we
use the case group or case projection to
obfuscate up the R value of the set
which means obfuscation will be Sigma of
set size applied to R of the cells
uh
and the in multilateral map you are
given Oracle access some access to the
group structure so given the label of
some elements a in the S group and the
element B in the JS group uh in one
Oracle query you can get uh the label of
a plus b in the I plus JS group
um
so in particular you have an oracle that
takes a simple i j Sigma I a and sigma J
B then output Sigma I plus J of a plus b
uh so first the hope is that since each
Sigma I it's like a random it means that
the adversary has no idea of uh like the
address looks at the label and has no
idea about what the underlying group
element is but given the access to this
multi-layer map Oracle you can still
perform some kind of decryption
I also want to remark that if you have K
labels and you want to add up all of
them then it's easy to see you just call
the Oracle came as one times and you can
add up them together
uh
okay the crash course and
now uh let's use the Oracle to obfuscate
our encryption
we output RN plus one RN plus 2 are of
universal unit message and each are of
and r of each set then we just replace
them by the office location
in particular for each set x i we use uh
the like size XS
projection to obfuscate it
and uh uh I think uh this part is like
most the most technical part in the talk
so uh any questions
okay
and some intuition is like so I'm I will
not tell you the proof of security but
some intuition about the security is if
there are no exact power then uh the
label of
no then the value of the universe and
the value of each exercise will be
independent in some sense
okay uh this goes to nearly the end of
my talk so let me wrap up and uh and
show you the complete reduction from if
exact color to amose
first we will need the notion of Oracle
in his encryption
and uh you can prove unconditional
security with respect to some carefully
design oracles
second you can show Oracle when this
encryption implies NP hundreds of MSP uh
in your construction you have you
actually have two oracles stick together
the first Oracle is the one under which
one is computer exists the second one
stores the ciphertext for like the
encryption for each fi
now if you want to reduce exact color to
Gap and Moses what you do is first you
get input uh and exact cover instance
which has some jigsaw pieces x i and
then you sample a random trustable f
uh you sample and Oracle om from the
generic multinational map model which
means you sample the uh the random
permutation Sigma 1 up to Sigma n plus 1
and you construct an oracle that
computes this this thing
so this is your o1
O2 is some Oracle that stores the
separate text so for each uh for each
eye you witness encrypt f i and the
store the ciphertext into O2
the several text Will consists of
obfuscations in the sense described in
per slides the obstructions of iron plus
one arm plus 2 and the
universe Union fi and each of x i
um and finally our Oracle all will be
the unit of these two oracles
so this is the complete reduction from
exact cover to Gap Ms P
uh
if there are no questions then
precise
so it says
it's like AdWords of some large gap
times as so in the pfk you can uh in the
yes case you can uh the certain
complexity is comparable to the
compressive decryption which is
polynomial in the length of 5 and the
Lambda where Lambda is Logan
and in the no case you need two two
Epsilon Lambda sets to compute the truth
table we're absolutely some Universal
content
so you can just set Lambda to be like
large constant times login
any other questions
[Music]
again is that particular reason you need
Auto to give up acceptance
because we can think of apps as a set of
questions you have capital and questions
and for each question you you store the
answer in O2 but with an encrypted form
so you will need to answer each of the
questions
foreign
what is this r r n plus one RN plus two
and
the current implementation
let's say you just are given some like
Oracle implementation with this
encryption because it works for any or
equipment right oh that's true and just
plugged it in our particular
organization okay but so if you're given
an arbitrary Oracle implementation of a
description what would it be then oh
then it will be like
oh oh to uh simply store the uh the
encryption of each file it says that our
encryption happens to be this format if
you are given a visual Oracle when the
solution then how to adjust storage
with this encryption of each other yeah
we're all like yeah and eyes what's from
one two
oh so I is the input of f f is a
function over let's say a little input
and I is a string of length little n or
iPhone index from zero to cap capital
something like that
so so if you're given uh with this
encryption for free
so like uh I'm cctp is uh yeah I believe
because
uh in the clear right instead of having
as an oracle like O2 you can just give
it right yeah
but we already know how to prevent the
hardness if we're giving cryptography
but through two table is small like f is
small
oh that's true
the conditional results in our paper is
that yeah we have some conditional
results which is assuming like with this
encryption of the conditional time from
the common growth capacity is can be
hard oh the condition okay yeah and
actually why would it be conditional and
not uh we still need to intuitively we
still need to score or two we just get
rid of o1 but not O2 yeah okay so two
needs to belong to your inputs
[Music]
uh first and most SP can be seen as
conditional circular competition and
second if you talk about conditional
time boundary from both complexity then
there are two regions one subminary
region one super linear region uh the
unconditional result for sublinear
regime where one doesn't have time to
read all the conditional streams
uh so I already thought for like super
linear regions so it's like uh can we
give an accent or given why can we
produce eggs in the same time uh much
larger than one or or we can't do it
even with time much much larger than one
but so in the sublime regime like this
Oracle is probably only need a column
electoral globes that you throw one
right so you could use like in a sub
linear regime
could you get a PCP free
and become hardness or MP complete this
for mc2p oh yes we did that yeah
any other questions
they're hopeful getting a worst case the
average case reduction for mlcsp uh good
question I don't so this is without
dozen for for mlcfp
um had some results on the measure of
information which holds for like uh
super linear time uh conditional time
boundaries from a growth capacity
through
do we get like uh unconditional results
for other problems
like you have a local access to kind of
like construct it's unconditional
results
in this paper are our Oracle
so uh I don't know if uh
um
since okay
um even though you're using Oracle
results I think your results overall
doesn't relate to work so yeah that's
true because we are this exact power to
I mean you're using and like there's no
no you know though even the witnessing
crypto encryption using
multi-linear Maps Okay use it to do
business encryption if the circuit
you're trying to encrypt has Oracle
Gates yeah that's true we need to start
with exact power you don't know how to
realize the exact power
okay so uh I don't have much time so
there is a summer uh I hope both
complexes and cryptographers have some
take our message from the talk for
competencies you might be interested in
like new techniques for proving and
behind us of meta complexity which gives
you very large airport for
cryptographers
uh I hope two account means that you
have the right techniques to tackle the
central province in metal complexities
and uh here it's a summer of our
techniques we combine gjsw with the with
the right Oracle model to get Oracle
witness encryption with unconditional
security which in turn implies and
behind us of ammo set speed with uh I
still want to advertise it's large
airports Gap and average time is in the
no case and thank you
foreign
no it doesn't because it reduces exact
color to mlcsp not like set to or I'll
go to Ms periods another Oracle
uh no so now we're actualizing Technique
we use is that exact color is empty
complete
okay
any other questions
um
I I want to do something like this but I
don't have ideas like I try to build
that job because I did about so I felt
because uh the name idea is to send a
Circle C and uh like evaluate so
certainly on my random input but
evaluated in the circus today it takes
too much time I want to add like as in
the truth songs like some artillery
input that helps the verifier rather the
circuit but I don't know how to do
something maybe you can do using some
clever ideas
destiny
[Applause]
type in everybody